the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and a
song of ice and fire theory video
in this video i will be discussing what
i think is one of the best kept secrets
in all of westeros
this is a subject i have whenever before
in one of my videos many years ago but i
want to talk about it again because i
still think it's interesting
now as you all know we are led to
believe there were only a handful of
characters who knew about the real
relationship rhaegar targaryen had with
lyanna stark
not only that but we are also led to
believe even fewer characters knew about
their secret love child jon snow
this would be a secret that ned stark
would take to his grave
thanks to the three odd raven and brian
stark we would eventually find out a lot
more information regarding lyanna and
rhaegar's relationship
as we saw in the show during some of
branstar's flashbacks we found out
exactly what happened at the tower of
joy
as well as how ned stark ended up with
jon snow a motherless child
as you all know this was when jon snow's
real mother and father was revealed
we finally had the answer to one of the
greatest mysteries in a song of ice and
fire
jon is the son of rhaegar and lyanna
making him next in line for the iron
throne
now as far as we know the only
characters who were aware of this
information were those who were there
that day
and were still not exactly sure how much
sir arthur dayne and his men
knew but since they died anyway it
doesn't really matter since
dead men don't speak and now the ned
stark is dead as well
the only other man who could have
revealed this information was helen reed
but i don't think he was the only one
who knew about jon snow
as a matter of fact i believe the
three-eyed raven gave this information
to someone else besides brian stark
i think the other character who knew
about this was maester aemon and it was
for a good reason
i actually believe the three-odd raven
was giving maester aemon information
all the way up until his death now let
me explain
if you haven't read any of the books you
might not know that much about master
aemon's relationship with not only the
three-eyed raven
but jon snow's father rhaegar targaryen
as well
i know i'm not the only one who always
got the sense that mr amen knew about
everything that was happening around him
now some of you might be wondering how
maester aemon would have known about all
this information
especially if he really didn't know
about rhaegar lyanna and
jon there is one very interesting detail
you must remember about these characters
the three-eyed raven maester ayman
rhaegar and jon snow are all related
all of them have the blood of the dragon
running through their veins
in fact the three had raven and jon snow
both have the blood of the dragon
as well as the blood of the first men
making them ice and fire
now one of the main reasons i believe
the three-eyed raven and maester amen
stayed in contact with each other over
the years is because of their
relationship with one another
these men were actually a lot closer
than you might think
the three-eyed raven also known as the
three-eyed crow or bloodraven
did not always live out beyond the wall
inside a weirwood
long before that he was known as lord
brendan rivers the bastard son of king
aegon targaryen the fifth of his name
there was already a lot of secrecy
surrounding this character before he
became known as the three-eyed raven
as a matter of fact there were many who
would say that he was a sinister
sorcerer and a spymaster who effectively
ran the kingdom with his spies and
spells
not only was he once the hand of the
king but he was also the master of
whispers
and he would continue to do the latter
even after he disappeared while ranging
out beyond the wall
so as you can see the thread raven has
been whispering secrets in the ears of
those who would listen for many many
years
now what is really interesting about
maester raymond and the three-eyed raven
is that they joined the night's watch on
the same exact day
they actually left king's landing and
rode up the castle black together
and i must say i would love to know what
they discussed during their long journey
now we all know emon became the may
strike castle black
but the three-eyed raven eventually
became the lord commander at castle
black
working hand-in-hand with maester ayman
we know how close maester aemon and lore
commander mormont were while they were
at castle black together
but how close do you think maester aemon
and the three-eyed raven were while they
were at castle black together
especially considering they were family
as well you can only assume they must
have had thousands of conversations over
the years
brendan rivers or the three-eyed raven
was the lore commander at castle black
for 13 years
so actually think about that maester
aemon and the three-eyed raven worked
hand-in-hand together at the wall for
well over a decade
and that was right before the three-eyed
raven disappeared while he was out
beyond the wall
maester aemon most likely would have
discovered some of his secrets while
living under the same roof
that is if the three had raven didn't
tell him himself which i think he did
once again this would have been for a
very good reason i also don't think it's
a coincidence that these characters
ended up living for over 100 years they
were among some of the oldest characters
still alive in westeros
it's almost as if they were staying
alive long enough until someone else
arrived
like they were waiting for something i
will get back to this later
now as i said before after he was the
lord commander at castle black for 13
years
brendan rivers eventually went missing
out beyond the wall
no one knew where he went or what
actually happened to him
but i believe maester amen did i believe
they stayed in contact
and even continued working together over
the years even if mr raymond didn't know
it was him
think about brendan river's other names
he was known as the three-eyed raven
the three-eyed crow or bloodraven he
knows how to look through the eyes of
the ravens but what we never saw in the
show was brendan rivers
also knows how to speak through the
ravens there were many examples of this
throughout the books
in fact he even influences different
events by speaking through the ravens
now think about one of the jobs maester
ayman had at castle black
he looks over the ravens the three-ad
raven also could have sent maece
draymond messages
through his dreams just like he did with
jojen reed bran stark
and maybe even jon snow there are a lot
of characters who see
different events in their dreams and
most fans believe it is bloodraven who
is affecting them
another thing that i find interesting
about maester ayman and bloodraven is
they both had something happen to their
eyes
mace raymond is obviously blind and
bloodraven lost one of his eyes
in the books the werewolf is actually
growing through bloodraven's empty eye
socket
now i'm not sure if there is any
significance to these characters having
had something happen to their eyesight
but george rr martin most likely did
this for one reason or another
now getting back to may streaming's old
age it almost feels as if something was
keeping him alive just long enough until
he could ensure
certain events happened at castle black
what are the odds that he would be able
to survive for that long in such a harsh
environment
only to die shortly after jon snow one
of our main characters
became the new lore commander at castle
black if you ask me
i think may draymond was waiting for him
under orders from the three-eyed raven
we now know the three-eyed raven can
look through the werewoods at different
events
even some that haven't happened yet i
believe things were set in motion for
certain characters to be in certain
locations
at certain times i think that mr amen
was there at the wall
as sort of a guide to make sure these
things still happened
now what's also really interesting is
maester aemon was well aware of the azor
ahai prophecy
in fact he actually spoke about this
with rhaegar targaryen
he knew that rhaegar was convinced it
would be one of his own sons who would
fulfill this ancient prophecy
now i would be willing to bet that
maester aemon spoke about this with the
three-eyed raven as well
i mean they did spend 13 years together
at the wall
i'm sure his conversation with rhaegar
had to come up eventually
this also has always made me wonder why
rhaegar became so obsessed with the
prince who was promised
what made him so sure it would be his
son where did he get this information
was it sent to him in a dream now the
targaryens are known for having
prophetic dreams
was the three-eyed raven influencing
these events once again
well i think so this is what ultimately
led rhaegar to fleeing south with lyanna
stark
he needed another son and as we all know
that son would be jon snow
a character maester aemon grew fond of
almost instantly
not only did maester raymond help jon
snow but so did the three had raven in
many different ways
for one it was no coincidence the starks
stumbled across exactly enough
direwolves for each of the children
including jon snow
what's also interesting about this is
how similar ghost is to bloodraven
they're both described as being white as
bone with eyes as red as blood
i believe that's because he is almost
always inside ghost
that way he could lead jon on his
journey of facing off against the others
in the books it was actually ghosts who
found the hidden stash of dragonglass
and what might have been the horn of
winter out beyond the wall
now who do you think hid those items
there in the first place
my guess is it was done by bloodraven
and or the children of the forest
since they do work hand in hand it was
also maester aemon
and the three-eyed raven who assisted in
jon snow becoming the new lord commander
at castle black
as we saw in the show it was mr amen who
gave jon snow the last
vote which ultimately won him the
election now in the books
they actually cast their votes inside
this giant kettle before they count them
when they opened it during the election
a raven flew out of it and landed right
next to jon
when that happened the raven said snow
the raven ends up saying jon's name a
few more times
right before it then lands on his
shoulder it was actually lore commander
mormont's old raven
however i believe it was the three out
raven inside of it
i think this is a good example of
maester ayman and the three had raven
working together
so they could ensure jon snow became the
new lord commander at castle black
another very interesting thing happens
with this raven
while jon snow is having a conversation
with lore commander mormont
during the conversation lore commander
mormont is actually talking to jon about
maester eamon's family
and their history most notably the
targaryen kings
i don't think this is a coincidence
because we now know jon is a targaryen
king as well
now before the conversation ends lore
commander mormont says
jaime lannister killed the last of the
dragon kings referring to the mad king
however as soon as mormont says that the
raven begins saying
the word king as it looks right at jon
snow
i think the raven is letting us know
jaime lannister did not kill the last
dragon king
because jon snow is a secret targaryen
next in line for the iron throne
and just like i said about the election
i think it was the three-eyed raven
inside of this raven saying king as it
looked at jon
something else i should mention is what
happens when stannis and melisandre
arrive at castle black
in the books as you all know melisandre
once believed that stannis was azor ahai
she even says that he has the sword
lightbringer as a matter of fact
stannis's sword even glows in the books
but we all know he's not the real azor
ahai nor does he have the real sword
like mace draymond knew this as well
he knew stannis wasn't a zora high and
he knew his sword was a lightbringer
because the blade was not hot
he actually says that to sam he said he
did not feel no heat when he was near
the sword
but as we all know lightbringer should
be a burning hot
glowing red sword stannis was not
melisandre was obviously using some kind
of magic to do that to the sword
now another thing i should mention is
what happens to maester ayman in the
books
he doesn't actually die at the wall like
he does in his show
in the books master raymond leaves
castle black for the citadel with
samwell
jon made sure that mace draymond got
away from the wall because he was
worried that melisandre might sacrifice
him for his king's blood now right
before mr amen leaves the wall
he says a few very interesting things to
jon snow
most likely knowing this would be the
last time they would ever speak to each
other
during this conversation this is when
maester aemon feels jon snow's face
before he gives him the kill the boy
speech what i find so interesting about
this
is when maester amen feels jon snow's
face it immediately reminds him of his
brother egg
or aegon targaryen it makes me think
there must have been something about
jon's bone structure in his face that
reminded aemon of his brother
who interestingly enough has the same
name as john
not only that but this was also the same
thing aemon said to his brother egg
right before he left king's landing for
the wall now maester ayman is giving the
same speech to another king aegon
which again i don't think is a
coincidence kill the boy jon snow
kill the boy and let the man be born
there
is one other thing maestraeman does
before he leaves castle black
he gives jon snow a book and this book
was known as the jade compendium
he lets jon know he left a marker inside
the book because there is something very
specific he wants him to read while he's
gone
when jon finally opens that book he sees
what maester aemon wants him to read
it was the section about azor ahai and
his sword lightbringer
now you could definitely say mace
raymond did that so jon would realize
stannis wasn't the real azor ahai
however i believe it has more than one
meaning
maybe he wanted jaunt to see something
in himself
something that maybe only maester aiman
a blind man could see
kill the boy jon snow kill the boy and
let the man be born
alone in the womb
it's a terrible thing
[Music]
[Music]
you